well this is a weird podcast
wait can i do an intro oh yeah
i know you have one in mine hi guys
welcome to what is hopefully going to be
the coolest evan and katelyn podcast
you'll ever listen to
[Music]
that's what we paused for music
hopefully that was enough time i
was thinking about how good your pun was
oh thank you thank you yeah i didn't
keep track of
i was like what's our intro song again
how long yeah we're
a little bit discombobulated because
we're in the middle of
uh the coldest weather houston has ever
seen
in or in probably the past like 30 40
years or something like that
yeah there's been a lot of once in our
lifetime events recently
i know too many too many yeah so it's
the i mean i've been calling it the
texas ice storm but i think a lot more
states are affected than
texas yeah i mean like the whole like
north pole
like like vortex of cold got like
thrown out of whack and sent you know an
ice
icy blast all the way down there the
north pole used icy blast on
america it was super effective
unfortunately
yeah so i think we figured we would
uh tell you guys how our experience has
been
yeah i mean we don't have any power we
barely have any water
it's it's cold but we do have batteries
for our cameras
so we might as well feel like we're
being productive
because we have problems not being
productive yeah i mean
we we can't make any progress on our
main project videos like stream
obviously we can't stream
we can barely use a computer yeah barely
i mean
you know you know sometimes your phone
can give it internet but we don't our
normal internet isn't working yeah
both of our cell phones are like running
extra slow
yeah um but i mean
overall we're very lucky you know we
prepared i got a little bit paranoid
after
hurricane harvey but i didn't really do
much about it and then going into
the pandemic year i actually got like
kind of paranoid about everything so i
bought a um you know a big battery
and solar panels that can charge it and
we've been living off of that
like and it's been making our lives so
much
so much more comfortable but i'm also
getting worried because
it's down to 40 it's down to 40
something percent yeah we're on day two
of no power and there's no sun today
yesterday we had sun to recharge so
we're kind of like
but i guess we can like kind of start at
the beginning
of our stories i think that i want to do
some more disclaimers just in case i
mean like
like you know we i think that that my
intent for this podcast is it for
just for it to be a fun story time
podcast
where we tell you guys about our
experience and kind of bring you along
with adventures
um we are in the middle of this and and
it is
fairly serious i mean yeah i was gonna
say like i don't think fun is really the
right word we're going to try to keep it
as lighthearted as well
because we're generally light-hearted
people but it is like
a serious situation yeah and i know that
for everybody a lot of people that live
in colder locations than this might be
thinking oh it's not that cold but i
think the big thing is
you know so many people aren't prepared
for it they don't know how to
drive in this weather we don't have snow
plows and
salt our houses aren't built for this
our cars aren't built for this
our plumbing inflation
so a lot of you people are going through
really difficult um
difficult experiences more difficult
than we are so when we're complaining
about
pipes and everything that's within the
context of we are very lucky
yeah so i do feel feel very nice we have
we have some wood we can burn
so we can like stay warm you know i
think that
that like i totally understand
fireplaces as functional objects now
after this because in texas like they're
they're they're actually
decor yeah i'm like oh no fireplaces
i am a big fan of fireplaces well we
were even
we'll get into like how we've been
trying to make food later
but we were even like you know what if
we run out of battery power we have cans
of beans
and we have a cast iron skillet oh we
could put that skillet and we could heat
up some beans
and chips like i'll do chips and beans
warm beans and chips warm beans and
chips
you know so fireplace functionality is
real so i think that's that's enough of
a disclaimer you know we're just
gonna be talking about our experiences
and it all starts
with um hearing about the winter storm
coming our way
i think the day before we were with our
family and
my mom was warning us that like it's
going to get like legit really cold
yeah the thing is what i was like
hearing from everybody and what i
saw was that there was going to be one
day
where it didn't get above freezing and i
think that the only thing that we were
worried about
is not being able to drive on the road
yeah so we
like you know got groceries and we're
we're like okay well you know like one
of the projects that we had
we were gonna film we were waiting on a
bunch of deliveries so we're like okay
well let's switch gears because
those deliveries are getting delayed so
we kind of
made some logistical plans and got some
food that we could cook and
um day one aside from
the leak well here let's so so we got a
little bit prepared we got some food
day one we wake up and caitlyn comes
like he yells back towards the brother
and like
evan yeah well that's what i was about
to get into it was the leak yeah the
leak yeah yeah i
i wake up and we had run our faucets
overnight just like
barely a little drips yeah um because
you know it's supposed to freeze and
that's good practice oh wait can i tell
about my straw
my straw invention okay okay so
the faucets are dripping drip drip drip
drip drip and our bathroom to our master
bathroom
to our master bedroom there's no door
there
so the faucets were dripping and i just
i have this huge pet peeve about
repetition that i just cannot
stand i think this isn't your pet peeve
about repetition i think it's just like
a loud noise kind of yeah noise yeah so
like i knew it was going to be hard to
sleep so i
jumped up and i ran into the kitchen and
i got some straws
and i connected the the
the faucet that was dripping to like the
drain thing
and it created like this laminar flow
down in there
and then it was nice and quiet so i
think that was that was the first
invention
of of the ice storm we benefited from
that very much
we really have so we ran our our faucets
like on a slow drip overnight because it
was going to freeze
and so i wake up in the morning and i'm
going to the kitchen to get jube her
breakfast
and there's a huge puddle of water on
the floor huge puddles
and my first thought was like did our
sinks
overflow or something because we ran
them like
maybe there was like a clog in the drain
and it just started filling and i'm
looking at the sink i'm like what's
going on what's going on
and then i hear the drip and i realize
that it is dripping from our ceiling
and there are two leaky spots in our
ceiling
so we clean up the water evan goes into
the attic
yeah i'll let you take it from there
since you were the one up there
i think that my first trip up there was
just like an exploratory trip
trying to find it and um we were there's
there's a vent near the drip and we kind
of use that
to like triangulate the location of the
drip
but the weird thing is um the place
where the water was hitting
our our ceiling was about like two feet
away or like a foot and a half away
from where the actual leaky pipe was so
i was in the attic for
so long we don't have good like
footing over there i'm just like
balanced between these two things
leaning over like oh my gosh trying not
to fall
and like by the end of this whole st by
the end of that whole day i'm kind of
jumping ahead
my legs were like shot i know that's
like a weird detail to include but like
it's so weird so much squatting
never worked out my legs so much in one
period
as i did squatting trying to find the
leak and fixing it and everything yeah
but you did find it
yeah so so thankfully i brought a tape
measure up there and i found it and i
was wearing gloves so i was able to
run my hands along all these pipes but
there's so many false
positives because and i didn't even tell
you all this because
i i don't know i don't know i just said
like i found it
yeah and we moved on because we just had
to go um
but there are multiple pipes running
through that area
and i found water under each of them
at some point because the water was
flowing from the leaky pipe
down along the insulation through
everything it was like you know there's
a puddle up there and a puddle down
there not really a puddle but like
there was wetness um in multiple
locations and i kept on like saying
visit and i would like would like i
brought some paper towels up there too
smart and i would like wipe it down and
try running my hand through there again
and there's no water the thing that
finally did is i kept on like rummaging
around and like
running my hands along things and um
i actually had to remove there's there's
some insulation
along our hot pipes to keep it hot um
and i had to remove some insulation from
them because i couldn't tell where
where it is it was a hot pipe it's a hot
pipe and there's a little tiny pinhole
leak
on it and i finally was like running my
handle on all the pipes all over the
place
like spreading my search out wider and
wider and wider
until i finally heard a noise and the
noise is the thing that finally let me
hear it
because the leaking pipe was going
like making a noise it was peeing so
i i found it and we had brought a little
tin pan up there
to collect the water um and i put the
tin pan
there and i came downstairs and i just
kind of started pacing
and kayla can describe the mood i get in
when i'm brainstorming
i just like like have this lost
lost look on my face and i just wander
the house yeah looking for inspiration
and i was just trying to like come up
with a way to stop the leaking pipe
because normally the way you do it
is you'd run to the local home goods
store get a
pipe clamp and clamp it but roads are
stover
yeah and we had been looking online and
you know we'd been
prepared you know prepared for it we
knew that like roads were going to ice
over
and yeah we looked online and you know
all of the government officials all over
the place were saying stay off the road
stay off the roads
so you know we're not just like rule
followers we're suggestion followers too
um because they didn't make it illegal
yeah but so um
i looked around and from the uh
underwater stream um we had some gasket
materials
i'd ordered all sorts of gasket types
and everything trying to get that seal
to work
and so we had various gasket materials
left over i'm like
all right so i have something to create
a seal now i need to apply force
um but i also want that force to be
evenly distributed so i need a backing
plate of some sort then i started
looking around
for backing plate materials and i
settled on the flashing
from the the catwheel and we've used
that flashing for all sorts of various
things right it's nice just to have like
just have metal flashing on thin sheet
metal around that you can
do stuff with um
so yeah i grabbed that for the backing
plate i grabbed some double stick tape
to attach
the everything together actually some of
the gaskets did have
you know yeah details details anyways
and then i started searching for some
way to clamp it
and i was looking at like um you know
strap clamps or
pipe clamps or all sorts of various
things and i finally found the right one
we clamped it it seemed to be working
and you can pick up the story from here
um sorry that's long detailed no it's
fine
it's fine i mean it's still kind of your
story to tell but
basically um wait is this when i went up
yeah i think that like i was done at
that point oh yeah this is when i would
okay yeah yeah yeah
but like you know so i i went up to go
check on the leak
this was um several hours later before
bed
um and uh i get up there
and the tray is over halfway full
um so we you know based on when we did
it we
knew that it wouldn't last overnight
even if we emptied it
so um we knew that we were gonna have to
like tighten it or fix it or
something um but first i had to empty
the tray and so i got i had brought up a
solo cup with me because the trays are
those little like um
kind of wobbly foil trays that are like
disposable things to use and like the
grill
and stuff yeah they're thin and weak and
kind of floppy
rectangles and so i brought up a solo
cup to dump the water into
what was that oh god that was you that
scared me
i just wanted to screw just a little bit
so they could see the fire oh okay
just because like we're we're we're like
you know we're absorbing the fire but i
just want i just want them to enjoy i
need to get these
cozy vibes vibes yeah so
i dumped the tray into the cup but
there's also a couple other trays
up there from when you were like working
on it and so the solo cup ended up being
literally filled to the rim
and now i have to trek back across the
whole
house worth of attic and it's tricky and
it's
treacherous it's very treacherous it's
hard to see things because we've blown
insulation so it's hard to like see what
you're doing
we don't trust it and like
i realize that i'm not comfortable
walking back with one hand
holding water and i don't want to spill
it because i don't want to cause another
leak
and so what i ended up doing is i would
like plant both my feet have the cup in
my right hand
grab onto a beam with my left hand i
would reach for i'd like squat down
reach forward set the cup ahead of me
stand up grab onto things with both my
hands because i'm only comfortable
moving if i have like three points of
contact
so i don't like taking i don't like
lifting a foot to take a step if both my
hands are not
locked onto something i don't blame
and so that i would step forward squat
down again reach behind me
grab the cup move it forward so it's
going to be so long to like
barely ooch along yeah i mean the main
treacherous part is this part of our
house right behind us
actually where there is um there's a
skinny part of our attic
there are two ducks there are like
several lights
there's a gas line there's a um
uh uh at least two plumbing lines
there's power cables running all over
the place and it's all a very narrow
thing you have to step over the the
ducting multiple times
and the light boxes and yeah and it's
all
um and it's all uh um
on the ground nothing is run along the
joists
which is something that i wish yeah was
the case yeah anyway yeah anyway
like we're going so deep down the leak
story which doesn't i don't think it was
even caused by the cold i don't know
i don't know why i don't know if it was
caused from us running our pipes
overnight and our pipes aren't used to
running our sinks overnight and our
pipes aren't used to that yeah
um it's sad because it messed up our
floors yeah it really did it so like
and we have some extra boards somewhere
but we're probably gonna have to have
them replaced and hopefully we have
enough because it's pretty bad
it's pretty bad um which makes me very
very sad yeah
yeah yeah like the floors was like the
first like
ooh splurge we're gonna get like like
maybe they weren't even that much of a
splurge because we got laminate not wood
and if we'd gotten wood maybe they would
have held up a little bit better than
the laminate yeah but like
they were our first like treat yourself
home investment
well we paid someone else to do it
instead of doing it ourselves yeah and
we were like oh we are
adults we own a home and we have nice
floors
yeah i have a strong attachment to these
floors that's very sad to see such a big
area bus stop
yeah me too just like right in the
middle of like
the main area it's not like tucked in a
corner or something it's just
you know i think it's really interesting
like doing this podcast with you because
like
like we are more fully stopping to tell
the story to each other
too and like reflect on things because
like i think that honestly we were so
in such go mode in the moment yeah but
also even since then we've been like
okay
how do we like like you know get solar
going how are we going to cook
how are we going to like clean things
you know our garbage disposal you know
it's just been like you know i'm kind of
jumping ahead a little bit but it's kind
of just been
problem solving mode ever since
that yeah for like 48 hours and also for
two like
highly productive driven people it's
it's been hard
to like you know stay
you know feeling good about that it's
hard to just sit on the couch and
also our our past times our video games
and um
internet anything is requiring internet
yeah and we can't do that much either
yeah um anyways but we're going back to
the to the oh yeah no
no going back to us reflecting it's
interesting like us fully
sharing the story with each other about
feelings
because like it's interesting because
like we didn't talk about it much
up until this point yeah you know we've
been going through and i think that
we've
you know chatted some about how we're
doing but like not all the details it's
just interesting it's just i was also
kind of sad that i didn't film
oh yeah i kind of like wish that i had
filmed the leak
and like filmed discovering it the whole
saga because
i'm like man it probably would have made
an interesting video but it was like
like we're not vloggers so
like when we're gonna film something we
are like okay
let's get ready let's get all the lights
set up let's get the camera set up we're
going into filming mode yeah we have
like
a set that we film in basically in the
garage
and like if something unexpected happens
in our life our first thought
is fix the thing it's not oh we gotta
film this for youtube you know what i
mean i kind of wish that for this moment
i had filmed it because i
think it would have been interesting i
think that one thing that we can do
and you know we talked about this a
little bit afterwards but we do have
these like
really small cameras that are like
pretty good no matter what lighting it
is and like um
uh pretty good audio yeah so we don't
need a mic because i think they're like
you know when we film
yeah i don't want to get too down that
tangent i'm kind of like i apologize if
i am like
breaking you away from tangents but it's
because i'm we're running lights and our
camera and our mics and like batteries
and
power is valuable and i don't know how
long this camera is going to record so i
kind of want to like
get to the more parts of the story and
i'm glad you said so because because i i
think that i was wondering why you're
like rushing so much
i looked up these lights these lights
will last
hours the camera will last hours and the
the
everything will last hours okay so we're
totally good
okay guaranteed okay don't worry yeah
i've been a little like worried about
time
i wanted to like just relax and like
tell the story
i know this fire looks relaxing but i've
been like okay we gotta
oh we're only on the leak we haven't
even made it to day two no no no look at
me
okay that wasn't that deep breath
[Laughter]
i think you might need a sip of it okay
deep breath ready
do you feel relaxed a little bit
yeah okay i'll try not to be so like
no i try not to be the tangent police so
yeah like
the the camera battery will last the
mics are
completely good the lights are the only
concern but they're going to be fine and
we have other lights and we have double
a batteries that can run them and
we're totally good okay we're good okay
in terms of like lighting and led one
thing there's a big side tangent i'm
just gonna go down
like one thing we've been learning a ton
about is how much various
um like outlet or like various
activities cost in terms of like watts
and everything
like cooking heating anything to do with
water oh my gosh that that uses up so
much power
yeah but lights aren't bad so we're good
yeah
so anyways you had to fix the the redo
the whole uh
week one thing that's that's really
interesting that's that's a that's a
neat
little side benefit of us posting
the league story on social media is some
people on twitter
pointed out that the the method i use
where you have a gasket
and you have a metal backing
and you have these pipe clamps is some
people pointed out that that's the
same method that engineers on nuclear
submarines use
to fix emergency leaks on the nuclear
submarines
now of course they have much
like more polished like patches that
they put over it
but it's but yeah i thought that was
pretty cool
but like i was actually inspired by that
look
i watched the video um this is when we
still had power
so i watched the video and i was looking
at
the the patch they used and what
dramatic rubber that i thought it was
and one thing i realized is the rubber
that i used was
very weak rubber in a way it was a
soft durometer of a seal for a gasket
so um i like that because it could
really conform
with not much pressure but it can't hold
much pressure and it wasn't super strong
so i
upgraded the thickness and hardness of
the seal
i added more backing plates and i used
more
pressure to hold it down because that's
one thing that i learned
from from the nuclear engineers and how
they did it so i kind of used that
and i redid the the seal and
it seemed to stop it and it's held ever
since and that that was right before bed
and so we were just like i hope this
works and we went to sleep and then the
next morning i went up there and checked
it
yeah um this was yesterday morning
and it was dry so you know
i think i haven't been up there again
since that's the end of the leak story
you know
hopefully it holds until we connect and
we thought longer-term plumber fix out
here
we thought we were like oh man this you
know leak is kind of annoying but you
know at least we have power
at least we have water you know at least
there's that and
you know we can handle the leak yeah and
then and we went to bed
with that thinking like okay we got it
fixed and then we woke up
at 3 a.m with no power yep
yep everything's shut down everything
shut down
so um which is fine you know we
uh we went back to sleep and
just figured we'd like deal with things
in the morning
um and we ended up not having power
all day yesterday yeah and
basically up until right now i mean we
had a short little burst of power
from midnight till 3 a.m
and like i like kind of jumped out of
bed and ran
out here and plugged in our big battery
to get it charging for as much as long
as it could
but um you know it didn't charge much
yeah but other than that three hour
window we haven't had power
since let's see it's wednesday
at like 11 or something right now we
haven't had power since
monday night yeah
three so i think it's been three a.m
so we're approaching like we're
approaching 36 hours aside from that
three-hour window
yeah which is like you know a decent
amount of time to go without heat
for a lot of people that don't have like
alternate sources and stuff
yeah i think it was really the fireplace
i mean we've been doing okay
heat wise it's in the 50s like the low
to mid 50s in the house it hasn't gotten
below
the 50s um i think the thing that we're
struggling with
is food because like it takes so much
well we haven't been struggling with but
that's the struggle i
foresee coming you know what one thing i
thought of that was super interesting
um thank goodness we did because you
said it didn't drop below the 50s inside
and i think the only reason for that
is because when we moved in here um you
know we realized that like the house
wasn't
that insulated and one of the first big
doi projects we took on ourselves was
blowing all that insulation and i think
every time we show
every time we show our attic everyone's
like what is
wrong with your attic what is all that
stuff everywhere what's all that stuff
that looks horrible it's blown
insulation
yeah and it's this like there's this i
don't know if it's
common or not but like well it was like
green fiber
so it's like recycled materials as
opposed to fiberglass because since we
were doing it ourselves
we didn't want to be like dealing with
fiberglass
yeah and like you know risking breathing
that in and stuff so that's why it's all
like dusty and dirty looking it's just
like we did that over the course of like
one or two weeks
installing all the soffits insulating
all of the lights that weren't insulated
radiating contact we
insulated the crap out of our attic we
insulated the crap and if it wasn't for
that
i wonder how cold it would have gotten
because we insulated
more than is required in houston so like
if we hadn't have gone
so like installation happy when we were
doing we're like well
we're up here we might as well just
insulate the heck out of it if we hadn't
done that how cold would it have gone
here i don't know
especially since when we moved in a lot
of the insulation was like literally
ripped down laying everywhere we had
bare spots
yeah this all over our house where it
was literally
like one sheet of dry of
of drywall in between us and
the elements kind of yeah i don't know
it could have gotten
much colder yeah yeah it's interesting
i'm just like
patting ourselves our past selves on the
back for doing that work back then
yeah because we thought it was just
about saving energy but it's also been
keeping us warm i know
yeah i mean yeah i don't know how much
of a difference it made but i'm glad
that we have it just in case
yeah but yeah so we woke up we didn't
have any power
we got our um battery our like
big rolly battery running um to charge
just a couple things i think we just i
don't even think we started with
charging the fridge i think we just
or did we i don't know i don't know when
we started using it for the fridge
we might have just used it for like your
computer
um and we ran solar out the catio
because it was the smallest door yeah
into the house
yeah the smallest opening so we ran it
out the catio into the yard
to charge the batteries and we actually
had like a few hours of pretty good sun
yeah pretty good time we're like we
weren't using up
the battery it was staying pretty even
for a few hours
and we like hooked up the fridge um just
so like our food didn't go bad and we
have
like i'm so glad that we have these we
got these when we were doing evan and
katelyn cooking videos
we got these two little electric
skillets because our cooktop is not gas
so like when the power goes out we can't
use our cooktop at all there's
aside from i guess like a cast iron full
of beans
and the i don't know how we would make
warm food
yeah and so luckily we had that little
skillet
and we could we we made tacos
yeah and i had bought stuff to make guac
so we made tacos and guac
guac was
i'm so hungry i'm so hungry
but that made us realize just how much
power that little cook
that little cooktop yeah it takes it's
like it's
so much it drained our big battery
which is like you know supposedly like
you know but it's supposed to last you
like a lot like just cooking a meal
dropped us like
how many percents like eight percent or
something eight percent
just to cook tacos just for tacos i know
it wasn't even
wasn't even cooking for that long it was
just crazy
and you had already cooked it you were
just reheating it yeah yeah i had
already cooked it
yeah i was just reheating imagine if we
had to cook fresh
no no it would have taken so long would
have taken so yeah luckily i was just
eating stuff um yeah and that made us
realize like okay we're gonna have to be
really
conscious of what we cook like i had had
plans to do like this big
pressure cooker meal but it was like
that's a lot of heat and a lot
i don't know exactly how much heat but
it's a lot of like time to cook you know
the pressure cooker you make like big
batches
and that's an inefficient use of power
because we're only going to eat a single
serving so we only want to use enough
heat required
to cook a single serving yeah and so
like all the
prepping we had done some of it we're
getting to use but like some of the
stuff that we had prepped we just hadn't
expected our power to be out this long
and so like we're not really able to eat
it so we're kind of getting creative
around the house one thing that's
interesting that i realized is
you know as people who are kind of like
generally always filling up our lives to
the point where we don't have much time
time is very valuable to us and i think
that um
you know i feel really lucky that we can
run the fridge and freezer because i
think the thing that would like
upset me the most if things spoiled in a
fridge and freezer
are losing all of the meals that like
mainly caitlin
has like invested time and effort and
like
all this like we have so many homemade
sauces and soups and
like taco ingredients and like so
much like that like we've put a lot of
time into these delicious delicious
things
that my mouth is watering thinking about
because i can't eat them right now
well like i'd just be really sad to like
lose all the time that we put into it
i don't know it seems silly you don't
want your freezer like
melting yeah yeah that's a big pain
if it gets a certain point you have to
like unplug it let it like evaporate out
dry it out and start over again yeah
yeah and so like so we mostly use the
um the battery to keep the fridge going
and to twice a day cook
um for yeah
for dinner we ended up making ramen
which was like the most time efficient
to like power efficient yeah yeah just
boil water
just a small amount of water boiling
water actually like
is yeah like cooking pasta wouldn't be
good i'm actually going to move down
move down and i'm going to take the butt
pillow oh yeah go for it
is your head okay it's still
visible um but yeah yesterday was a lot
of like
shenanigans with the solar like you had
to keep
because like we have a lot of trees in
our neighborhood which is great
i love trees but also like one thing
that i'm realizing with solar is like
like if direct sunlight
100 direct not like reflected not
anything like that it has to be like
direct sunlight has to hit the solar
panels
if it's not that it's like barely doing
anything um
it's a cloudy day today i'm kind of
jumping ahead again but it's a cloudy
day today and i checked to see how much
power was being generated
by our solar panels and it's like
basically zero
yeah when it's like really overcast like
this it really needs to be like
direct sunlight which is we only got
that
to me a few hours yeah yesterday and
like i'm really grateful that we had it
it's at least something
um it really did help yeah it did help
yeah um
but we were kind of like okay you know
we thought we'd be able to run our
computers
and get work done and that's really not
practical like we need to
save power for the purpose of food
basically
yeah like so we're not we we had like um
these little heating pads that we're
like oh we'll stay warm we'll like wrap
ourselves with the heating pads under
blankets and we're like nope
like we need to use our power our
limited battery supply
for food yeah or for whatever else you
know who knows
i mean something else might come up yeah
but like you know work is less important
yeah yeah it is work is less important
than eating
i mean we have like we have so many
chips we could just eat
chips but yeah we could just eat chips
but we didn't really we weren't super
prepared with like meals that don't
require
heating we can eat cold beans i don't
want to eat cold beans i want to put
them in the fireplace
this is weird that like like thinking of
like
fireplace warmed beans and cheese makes
me excited to eat it yeah it does sound
kind of good actually like i do just
kind of want like a skillet of warm
refried beans and cheese and dip chips
in it we have so many salsas
i can make guac i can make more guac
anyways it sounds kind of good but i am
a little worried about like
like putting the beans in here and we
have we only have a couple
logs what we mostly have is like fire
starter bricks
yeah and like are those gonna put off
weird fumes that you can't cut beans
over you might need to do some internet
searching on that yeah
anyways the beans are the backup
hopefully we don't need to get to the
back up
yeah it's been almost 36 hours like
hopefully we have power soon
yeah there's been a lot of shenanigans
like one day one time like yesterday
i was just kind of walking around the
house just checking on things i don't
really know why i was walking around i
think you're
like moving the solar maybe looking for
some spots oh yeah and i just heard like
a sound
that seemed out of the ordinary so i
walked around the house trying to find
it and i realized that
our neighbors plumbing had like burst
and was like
spraying everywhere so you know i got
them and and you know
they they were able to shut that down
and everything but yeah it's like oh
scary though just seeing like a huge
i'm just playing up our notes yeah just
seeing like a huge
plume of water and i was watching
through the window and he tried to like
close it and it sprayed him in the face
cracked even more
yeah it was just spraying everywhere
it's like this this is why i like
you know i'm not saying that cold
weather elsewhere isn't a big deal
because it's
you know cold weather in my opinion is
not my favorite at
all that's why we live down here i
probably live down here but like you
know cold weather down here is so much
like kind of not dangerous isn't the
right word but it is it is
people don't know how to handle it it's
worse down here because
all of our plumbing are like run
outdoors which
yeah it makes me curious like i'm
curious to see like how northern houses
are built
that makes them more weather resistant
maybe there's deeper into the ground so
deeper into the ground or there
or something or maybe they just have
more insulation around it
because like pipes out here in in texas
are just like
run like that our breaker boxes are
outside yeah definitely
in some places i didn't realize i was
weird until it was in a video and
everyone's like why is that happening
isn't it outside
yeah but like it's just it's just well
even like so much texas power i learned
is from
like wind power and it's not like the
um like they had to be shut down a bunch
of them because the weather yeah
there's a lot of things so like texas
lost like a quarter of its power just
due to those being shut down but even
generators like you know
you know generators in colder areas i'm
sure
take cold weather into account but like
houston
probably has generators that can handle
hot temperatures way better than
than yeah up north but like down here
like they evidently everything wasn't
ready
and winterized you know so so many
generators and
various things failed because
of um you know they weren't ready for
these conditions
yeah which is interesting um so
hopefully
hopefully there's a lot of lessons
learned from this and you know
the reliability can increase i hope so
but i don't i don't really know if
there's gonna be that much they can do
just because this is
i mean this is like the worst the
coldest texas in 32 years like how much
can you invest in something that
happened so rarely
yeah you know so i'm i'm not sure
but um but yeah
and our families have all lost like
various levels of
conveniences too like um
your parents had power the first day i
believe same as us but they've
been they were without power power
yesterday and today it seems like it's
on and off for them
your sister lost power all of day one
for day two she's leaks in her ceiling
her water pressure is almost gone her
water pressure is almost gone yeah our
water pressure is almost gone today too
it's like a trickle
one thing that's interesting is like we
found out through oh sorry go for it oh
i was just gonna say um
and then my my brother's the only one
that's okay who has water and
power my parents oh my parents have it
the worst
parents oh my god they're on well water
and
their pump for that is outside and the
pump is powered
and so when the power went off the water
stopped running and
the whole thing burst the pipe the main
pipe from like the receptacle
fell off it just like exploded off and
so
they have drinking water in the house
but they don't have water for like
like dishes or toilets or baths and so
they're like
bringing water in from the pool you know
and it's just like a huge thing and
they've they've been without water for
like
over two days now yeah and there's not
really like a fix
in sight because yeah like it's hard to
get
people out there to fix things well i
think that another thing that's scary is
since your parents don't have running
water their pipes might freeze more yeah
so the extent of the damage is unknown
yeah
and the the time in which they can
fix it is so unknown because also guess
what's going to happen
once the roads are drivable again all of
the plumbing supplies all across texas
are going to get bought up
all of the plumbers are going to be busy
for like two months
trying to fix all of this extensive
damage because
there's extensive damage everywhere and
i think it's i think the logistical uh
it's gonna be it's gonna be like you
know after harvey there's so many
like um houses that are flooded and
damaged
yeah they're dealing with water damage
like supplies
everywhere were low and you know all
contractors were busy and stuff i think
it might be
similar here just because like the
amount of
plumbing damage just all across um
uh houston and other states that have
been affected by this
is bad and i think it's it's uh you know
i say interesting not in a positive way
but it's going to be i'm curious to see
how long the effects of this are felt
for
well it's also just been much longer
than we expected because we all went
into it think early so i went into it
thinking it was just kind of like monday
was really bad
and then it would get above freezing but
it's dipping into freezing temperatures
all week well there's two cold fronts
it's two different
yeah yeah yeah so so yeah one system hit
us
and we're gonna have like a little brief
respite where it's like
not as cold and then another one's
hitting us i believe that's the case
is that i'm not a meteorologist no no
yeah but like the the first one that hit
like
monday and sunday and are we in the
second one or is the second one still
coming no
still coming second one's still coming
yeah it's like
gonna get a little bit warmer over the
weekend it was supposed to get
like it's 60. oh no yeah so so
the second one doesn't seem to be as
intense it's actually
gotten better yeah i was like i don't
know if i can answer but but no no no i
know actually
no it's tomorrow and friday no no i was
just looking in the wrong place yeah
tomorrow and friday thursday and
saturday are gonna be
getting into the 20s yeah and finally by
the weekend it won't be freezing
hopefully by saturday it won't be
freezing
but like yeah the the the weird the
weird thing
that's that's only wednesday well the
weird thing about this whole situation
since this is like unprecedented in our
lifetimes
and you know this area hasn't
been prepared for this like no one you
know this isn't like a yearly cycle for
us where like our energy companies can
say
oh this has happened before i know how
to fix it and it'll be fixed by this
period of time
like yeah like we're getting daily
updates from the power companies saying
it'll be your power will be out offer at
least all of today
there's no like estimated it'll be fixed
by date
so like the the crazy thing is we just
don't know how long
like power will be out how much do we
ration our power
yeah we'll be out for one day two days
three days four days five days i don't
know
i'm like i'm thinking it'd be
unreasonable for it to be out that long
but like me and my feelings have nothing
to do with the reality of the situation
yeah this is unreasonable whether you're
being unreasonable
oh yeah yeah hopefully i mean like one
thing that like
i wish that the the power grid people
here would do
is roll the blackouts a little bit more
they are in some areas and like last
night when we had
last night hour for three hours yeah so
so you know we went to bed we tried to
go to bed a little bit early
after day one yeah um just because like
you get to a certain point there's not
that much you can do everything is dark
might as well try to take advantage of
the the sunlight
yeah might as well try to go to bed
early so we went to bed at like 10 30
and then at 11 45 we woke up to the
power coming back on
and you know you like did your
shenanigans got the battery plugged in
and it was on for three hours and then
it turned off again and so we're like
you know maybe we're on like a three
hour rolling period now
and maybe it's 6 a.m power will come
back again
but it is 12 30 p.m oh no caleb we got
the email it says we're not going to get
power all today
oh we got that for today too i think so
no
i know we got it yesterday oh man yeah
i'm pretty i'm pretty sure i'll look it
up later but like you know
i'm pretty sure we won't have power all
of today i was really hoping we could
get power today
yeah okay well well you know we we still
might they may not expect it
but it might happen i'm not going to be
hopeful i'm not going to be hopefully
there i'm burying my hope
hope's gone hope's gone um
yeah but i i think one thing that i
spent a little bit of time doing
i know it like doesn't fully make sense
to like
go buy things like that you need now
that aren't going to come in for like
days or weeks but like you know while
i was noticing things around the house i
just started ordering things like
extra batteries you know um uh
another solar panel and then now also um
i ordered us like a dual fuel generator
to supplement the battery because the
battery is great because you can have it
indoors
you can recharge it with solar and all
this stuff but like when there's no
when there's no sun and it's an extended
period i think that i'm just going to
feel
really a lot better having like a source
of power for us just in case
and one thing we realized is like most
of the scenarios where we would lose
power will probably be weather things
like hurricanes and stuff like that and
in weather things you often don't have
direct sunlight
so it'll be good to have something else
it'll be really good to have something
else um
and again maybe we only use it once
every few years hopefully we don't have
to use it very often but like
that would make me feel a lot better now
it's a little it's just
it's like it's the same i think of it
kind of like
the cost of getting that is kind of like
similar to the cost of like
driving with insurance or having
homeowners insurance or something like
that it's like
you pay the cost and deal with the
like storage issues and all that stuff
just for that just in case scenario
i think we have some hot dogs in the
freezer could we make hot dogs
once we look off of that uh if that fire
log i guess like if it's not freezing
outside we could
try to crank up the grill we could try
to crank up the grill
anyway sorry i'm thinking about food i'm
getting hungry dude i know i'm getting
hungry
hot dogs sound kind of good right we
don't have bugs but we can just like
we got tortillas tortillas and hot dogs
oh we have like i think we have one
thing of mac and cheese oh no but we
can't boil water boil water tastes like
we found that out this morning we were
like
what's like a hot meal we can make that
won't take too much power
we have like little instant oatmeal
packets we're like you don't need to
boil much water at all for those
and we wanted warm tea well we're like
while we're boiling water we'll just use
whatever
we don't need for the oatmeal for tea um
thank you
so we we uh boiled or heated up our
little uh tea kettle thing to boil the
water
three percent loss three percent loss in
less than three minutes
it takes up so much power so much better
all of the things we've used that then
uses 1
500 watts um you know our
our our skillet didn't take up that much
power our refrigerator doesn't take that
much power
our chest feeder doesn't take that much
power we're thinking it would
i think it'd be in the 600s i was
thinking 600 similar skillet i was
thinking similar to the skillet
but like dang so we're not using that
anymore
we did enjoy our oatmeal and our at the
same time
it's probably about the same efficiency
because like i was thinking about it
like the amount of power it takes to
boil
water is a fixed amount you need to heat
it up to a certain amount you need to
put it inside
and it is faster it's faster so it's
like do you want it faster or slower no
matter that's a good point you matter
the uh
method it's still going to take some i'm
still going to take the same amount of
overall power that's true it was just it
just pains you to watch that battery
drain and you're like i hope this
oatmeal is worth it
is precious we're in the 40s now
and we won't have power all of today
yeah like it takes seven to get those
delicious tacos
i know and i want those delicious tacos
like that but maybe we can grill we do
have do we have propane
we have propane okay so maybe we can
grow some hot dogs
i have to go into the freezer we've been
keeping it closed and i don't know for
sure if we have any
anyways we'll figure it well if that's
the conversation
or after yeah that's not a podcast
conversation but we're
just getting people either hungry or
annoyed
yeah i mean but we're kind of getting
too to present time
now you know oh another fun thing is
there's a boil water notice
yep and as of today um
we uh our water pressure is like nothing
now
yesterday it was decent like we could
wash dishes and stuff but today it's
pretty tough to wash dishes and we have
a boil water so luckily we do have some
like
things of water yeah those that was
thanks to my paranoia
yeah when you bought the solar panels
and stuff i got some water it's
interesting yeah like buying that i felt
kind of silly i have to admit
i was putting all this time and research
into all of this and i'm like
oh am i wasting time i remember like
back then feeling guilty about like
wasting time and potentially wasting
money
prepping for like all of this stuff i'm
so glad that we have it i'm so glad that
we have it it's just interesting
yeah thinking back but i think that
another thing about this whole situation
is
like you know
each now this sounds
like like i don't know
hokey or something like this but i'm
just gonna say it anyways because
sometimes i'm
i'm a hokey type of guy um a little bit
corny
but like you know each difficult thing
that we go
through personally gets us more prepared
and more knowledgeable
for future scenarios who knows what
those feature scenarios are going to be
do you know like our our parents have
gone through a lot older generations
have gone through a lot
but like there's a big difference
between someone else knowing it
and you knowing it personally
yeah you know what i mean and this is
the first like
long-term power loss at least that i've
had ever had to go through as an adult
like not living with my parents
yeah like i've lost it for like an hour
you know here or there a couple hours
but never
anything like this yeah yeah i think
that um
you know there's so many lessons learned
um
like even as a an engineer who's taken
classes on like electrical engineering
like i didn't
fully realize like all sorts of various
things around power like
how much power extension cords oh yeah
add the inefficiency of systems
like the farther the solar panels are
away from the
the battery the less efficient
yeah the solar panels are the farther
the
um uh light or whatever
is from the battery the more power is
wasted
sending it through the cable and the
thinner the cable is
the worse it is the thicker the better
and the longer
it is the less bad and also the longer
the more bad
yeah oh yeah sorry the longer the cable
is the more bad
longer long and thin bad short and fat
good short bad good
and um also the the higher the draw is
the more the inefficiencies start
compounding and you can lose like
two to six to seven percent of
power due to bad cables so sad
so sad power so valuable power so
valuable so
it's it's just you know all these things
we're learning things that like you know
little nuggets of upgrades that we can
like you know
make in in this house and in our future
house that's one thing i've been
thinking about a lot
you know like one day when we like build
a house or or buy another house or
something like that
like i don't know i i think that all of
these nuggets that we've gained from
this experience will help me we should
make notes
we should make notes yeah that's a great
thing to do while we're just
sitting here in here yeah and i think i
think that that about
wraps it up what do you think yeah we
don't really have thing of the weeks
maybe we can link to the battery in the
solar panels or something yeah
you know oh yeah i'll i'll come up with
something
um but i think that um uh because i feel
like people will probably ask
people asked about it when we posted on
socials like the solar and the battery
so
we'll link to the our battery and our
our solars and if you have any other
stuff you want to throw in
they're all sold out well we can still
link to that link to them yeah yeah yeah
okay they'll be back eventually uh well
thanks thanks for joining
this very cool podcast
so cool um i hope
oh this podcast gave you chills no i
hope it didn't
hope it made you feel warm and toasty
well if i made you feel warm and toasty
um i think i think
there's it's weird because we don't know
the thing of the week what comes after
thing of the week
we tell people to give us ratings and
reviews oh yeah
i mean you can do that if you want you
can maybe just send warm thoughts our
way yeah
all right guys see you next time bye
[Music]
you